"
NANCY PELOSI SDINGFF A NEW
WA O FUR THREA AFTER
TOUCHING DOW IN TAIWAN.
GE AND WARNG T TRIPOULD
HAVEERIOUSONSEQUENCES.
NANCY LOSIETTING A ESCORT
OM TAIWAN'S AIRRTS RE
YING IN EARER TODAY THE U.
AND IWANN HIGH ERT WITH
FOUR AMERIN.
CHIN SET TRESPD WH LIV
FI MILARY DLLS SURROUNDI
TAAN NEW VID SHOWINGHINE
TAS ROING ON I COALINE.
BEIJG PING ON WIT THE
THRES AND SING ARICA WILLPAY>> A
REONSE WILL B STRONND
FORCEFUL>> NANCYELOS NOT BACKINY
OM TS FACE-OFF WIT TRAN
OUT THE WHITE USE
RESING T TAK A FIRM STAE
THERIP.
>> NHING HAS CHAED ABOUTUR
ONE CHINAOLICTHE SPEER HIGHT TO
AVEL.
SHE IS THE SPEAKER O THE HOU.
SHE I A MBER OF THEONGRS.
GOVERNME.AV TRAVELED T TAIWAEVEF
GAVER ADVICE AND COUNSEL
IN CONXT AND INFORMAON
VIOUY AS IS TYPICE A
HEING WITHHEIR
TRSFORMATI.
T TS IS A DECISN THAT OY
SHEANAKE A WE SUPPO AND
REECT THATECISN.
>> RUBLINS ARE CLINGUT
TH THE WHI HOUSE AREHOWI
WENESS AND PUTTINANCY PESI I A .
>>HIS ADMINISTRATIO SEE TO
AFRAID  EVE SP OF THEWAY OFROV.
D YOSEE WHAT'S HAPPENG I
SIGNALED THATHATE ARE NOT
I THINK THE SE TNG IS TR
RE.
WE AO RK-AVERSE.
AND  HE SHOD'VE SAID THE
LITA DIDN'T WANT H TOO.
TH ADMINISTRATIO SHOULD NOT
PRESOR N TO GO.WE CANNO ALL THET
CAN DO AROUNDHE WLD.ENS
>> GREG TFEL WHERE DO YOU
AND ON THEANCYELOSI TAIWAN
SITUATN?
>> THIS I SO INTERESTING
WAR WITH CNA AS WL ASUSSIA
WAS NOT O MY BINGO CD.
WE ND TO LOO BACT A O
THOSBIG THICK BOO WRIEN BY
IMRTAN PEOE.
ERE ARE ALL T PEOPLE WHO
ID TS WAS GOI TBE GREAT?
AND IT'SLLALLING ART.
I GO BACK T2017
IT WAS TERBLE TIME,HE
NISHG RELTLES
PSHOLOCAL TORTURE TT HE
USED
THINOF THEKUNK
W WE JUS HE INFLATION, T
CO WAR A HOT W, RAGINCRIME WAVES
EY'VE GOT NO TETS.
BUT TY ARPOINTHAT IS IS
TRIPRYING TO PRO?
PRACTICALOVE OROSTL
VIUE SNAL?
I FINDYSELGREEING WITH
PELE ION'T TST O
DIGREEING WITH OPLE TRUST.
'SNCREBLYONFUSINGHICH
IS W THIS STRAIGHT A GRE
STY BEAUTIESAVE THERIP
"THE NEWORK MES."
IF I SAVE THRIP ISOOD I
REE TH DRUDGI'M THE AL VICTI
I AGR WIT MITT MNEY ANDTRUMP BAY
ARON THE SAM SIDE.
THEYREAYING THIS I A
YOU DON'T WAN WOR WAR III TOBE .
A CGRESOMAN FRO CIFORNIA
D HERINTHECADE WITH A FAC
TITER THAN A SNA DRUM.
I GSS LE WHAT TCONGRESSN WAS SID
CHINESE WAING EN WE DIDT
NATO.RUSSIS WNING ABOUT
THAT WKEDUT SPLEND.
>> WHA ISHINA GOINGOONOW, JESCA?
THEYE MA LOTF THREATS
AN THEYIDN'CARRY THRGH
WITH THOSE TEATS BUT NOW TY
SAY RE I COMING.
>> I GUE WEAIT D SEEND
ARE AS PREPAD AE CAN BE.OBVIOUN
TAIWESEOVERNMENT SIT.
BUTO FAR THESERE ALL THINGS
THAT WE CAN BEAR INUPPORT OTAIWO
TH THING I FIND MOS
INTESTING IS WHAT
SENATOCOTT WAS SAYG, TT
E BIN ADMINISTRATN W
WHEN FIR HEA HER COMING EYESONII
'S OICIAL POLICYHAT
NANCY PESI'SHEREABOUTS ARENO KN
FOLLOW-UP
E'S IRD IN LINE,IGHT
AND IF ITAS T ADMINISTRATN
THAT'SNCREBLY A DAEROU
THINOO.
HE COULDE JU CLED HER ANDMAYE TG
THISOR A FOR DIFRENT
TIMI.
I'M SE NO SURE -- 4REBLIC SIGNIF
R, ILUDING MITCH MONNE
SANG TS IS WH SHOD BE
ALLIES.ITHUR TIME, MEY,
THAT'S KIND  A BOL MOVE TO
LEAVEHE TRIP IN THE DEN
ADMISTRATION WHA HE THITH WOU DR
D?
>>BSOLUTEL
ANTO ASSERT CONTR OVE HER
AND RE THAT E'S NOT THENE
NOTHE FOREIGN POLIC F THIS
ADMISTRAON.
I AEE WITH CRA.
I THINK THERE SHOULDE ME
DIUPTORS.
APPLECART UPSE DO AND SEEG
WHERHE APPLES LL.
I D'T TNK T CHAOS AND
DISRTION AREHE SAM THING AS
BEINGROVOTIVE.
SHE INOTECESSARILY PROKING
FOR.
WHAT SHE'SOING IS BNG AIT
UP FORREED.UT STILL SNDIN
THERE AAY TOO MANLeBRON JES AAY.
I THINK IT'SMPORNT TO TALK
OUT THE CT TT WE A N
USING THIS CONFLT, CNA IS
CAING THIS CONFLICT.
IT'S NOT UNCOMMON FOR
POLICIANSROM THE
UNITEDTATE TO GO T T ONE
IR THE ARENNDEPENDECOUNTRYND W D
MILLN DOLLARRADEGREEMENT
TH THEMT I TOTALLY NORL
R TH SPEAKER O T HOUSE TO
GO T TAIWAN TOISIT WITTHEI
LEERS.
SO XI JINPG ISUPPOSED T BE
APPOTED MPORARYOR LIFE.
THINK A LOT OPOSTING HERE
S TO DOITH OUT BUT ALS WE
ARE N PRERED FOR A LONG TE
FIGHITH CHINA.
CHINA  INLL OF OUR
STITIONS
THEYRE PFESSORS AND
UNIVSITIES ACROS THEOUNTRY
INTELLECAL PROPERTY. OUR
DURING THE BULIMICF WH HESWHICHT
AGAIT US AND T RES OF THE
WOD AFTERAUSI THE
PANDEM.
WE HAV NOTONE ENOUGHO TAK
OUR PPLYHAINS O OF AT
UNTRY.
SO CHI HAS INP ITSELF IHE
COANIEOLICIANS A U.S.
WE ARE N PRERED FOR
NG-TM CONFLIC I THI
TAIWAN SUATI IS VERSMAL
PIE ABT CHINA PLANS TO  IN
AS LONG AS W A RIANTNKGDEMANDS .
TH IT'S GOI TO BE AROBL
FOUS.
IS SHEOING TO RIREFTERREG?
TH LOS THE HOU?
IS THIS ARE DOING FAR EAST
SWING IS T BIG DIPMAT D
BURNISNG HER CRENTIA?
THAT'S A TERRIBLE REASO TO
DO TS,IGHT?
IS KINDF INRESTING WHEN
YOU SEE THO WHERE ARE THEY CHIN?
CAN YOU WEIGIN O THIS?
AL OFOU NBA PLAYERSF
ANODY ASK LeBN ABOUT TS
LATE?
HO MAN PEOPLE  IEAN W
KEEPALKI ABOUT DECOUPLG --
ARE WE DOUPLG?
DON'T THI WE E DECOUING
AT ALL.ITOESN SOUND LIKE TH MUCH
FUN